[Music]
on this thursday night the protests and
disruption spread from ottawa's airport
targeted
to border blockades at several key
international crossings supply lines cod
auto plants closing jobs are on the line
and the federal tory leader changes her
tune the economy you want to see reopen
is hurting
also tonight 30 000 russian troops begin
military drills in the black sea the
biggest security crisis that
europe has faced for decades and peak
performance canadian olympians rack up
more medals delivering one of their best
days at the winter olympics
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin again tonight with the protests
and disruptions in canada they're
spilling out to new fronts and putting
people out of work ford gm toyota and
other auto plants on both sides of the
border have had to scale back and shut
down because of this protesters blocking
the flow of goods across the canada u.s
border
and in ottawa trucks and protesters
continue to occupy streets near
parliament hill
and this happened at ottawa's airport a
convoy of vehicles circled honking and
shouting freedom at least one of them
saying ontario premier doug ford has to
go
get after your premiums get after we
want them gone
put someone else in charge for now
and uh we build from
there ottawa police report what they
call a concerted effort to flood 911
lines the force tweeting this endangers
lives and it's completely unacceptable
and there are several other sites apart
from parliament hill it appear to be
staging grounds for protesters
encampments to the east and the south
and reports of others including one more
than 35 kilometers away from the city's
center
that suggests the possibility of
tactical planning and strategy after two
weeks of this the pressure on
politicians and authorities to find a
solution is intensifying today the
leader of the federal conservatives
reversed course and said this
to all of you who are taking part in the
protests
i believe the time has come for you to
take down the barricades
stop the disruptive action and come
together
there is a lot to get to tonight we
begin with ross lord in ottawa
two weeks into the stalemate this
encampment has become a vital supply
depot for the occupation everything from
food to fuel protesters are receiving so
many supplies they're turning donations
away john bancroft who owns an excavator
business in british columbia is helping
coordinate there's no one has a job here
like there's no organization other than
canada coming together here ottawa
police say they've negotiated for a
dozen more trucks to leave this
encampment plus 10 others from another
part of the city but that's a small
percentage of the overall number
and other protesters say they are far
from finished some activity is from
anonymous sources an ottawa city council
committee meeting was hacked with an
unapproved message on youtube there was
also a flood of unnecessary 9-1-1 calls
that disrupted the city's emergency
phone system an active sabotage that
bancroft insists had nothing to do with
the so-called freedom convoy clogging
the lines that's going to create safety
concerns
proper emergencies that are actually
happening will not be able to get
through and that's not what we stand for
and i'll put my word on that ottawa
police say they've traced a large number
of the fake 9-1-1 calls to convoy
supporters in the united states
there are signs protesters are spreading
out disrupting traffic to the airport
among other areas making it harder for
police to contain it opening up
different areas different camp posts at
different parts of the city puts
different pressure on the police service
with their limited resources to try then
to deal with those particular areas the
federal government says more help is on
the way the rcmp are going to be sending
additional reinforcements to ottawa
i can also advise that the rcmp will be
sending
reinforcements to windsor
and in addition to that the rcmp have
added additional resources in coots and
alberta we have been enforcing the law
from day one for police there are some
victories like persuading truckers to
leave this downtown section well it's
good news i just walked out i arrived at
this corner moments ago and i said oh
great because last time i was down here
there were trucks up to nepean so
it's progress
but until all of the unwelcome visitors
leave life in ottawa is a long way from
returning to normal two weeks on
ross lord global news ottawa
now to the impact of canada's busiest
border crossing a peaceful protest is
legal in canada blocking highways in the
u.s canada border for days and
restricting the rights and freedoms of
others is not the protest on the
ambassador bridge from windsor to
detroit has cut supply lines and is now
costing jobs shawn o'shea is in windsor
for us again tonight sean
donna four days into this bridge
blockade both countries are starting to
see the economic impacts especially the
auto manufacturing sector
protesters refuse to budge and take
pride in the pain they're inflicting we
are costing the mayor doug ford all the
people a lot of money
this group is still camped on the
canadian side of the ambassador bridge
linking windsor to detroit on a normal
day 450 million dollars worth of goods
crosses here with a bridge link fully
closed manufacturers are losing business
and their employees are losing work the
potential for
more layoffs and
additional reduced hours is just going
to increase ford temporarily shut down
its engine plant here and cut a shift
from its assembly plant in oakville
stelantis formerly fiat chrysler
shortened shifts at several plants and
toyota said it would not manufacture
anything at three canadian plants for
the rest of the week the law needs to be
enforced this is too important of a
piece of infrastructure for the canadian
economy and this is now hurting canadian
jobs
the frustration attracting more american
media by the day when a fox news crew
showed up they were welcomed
enthusiastically by the crowd
contrast that with what outlets like
global news are experiencing over the
past day the first signs of police
tactical units have shown up ontario
provincial police have arrived too and
concrete barriers are being set up
designed to prevent more vehicles from
joining the blockade they need to step
up because clearly whatever they've been
doing
to this point hasn't been working more
here justify their actions even while
acknowledging their own neighbors will
be financially hurt by this shutdown
we're not the ones stopping this economy
trudeau has halted this economy long
before we're here that's why we're here
as for how long this protest could go on
that's anybody's guess but the governor
of michigan gretchen whitmer asked
canadian authorities today to do
something about it right now in her
words it's simple it's time to reopen
traffic on the bridge
donna
all right sean o'shea in windsor ontario
thank you well much of the disruption
and now the loss of jobs is happening in
ontario that province's liberal leader
has accused premier doug ford of being
invisible and now there are reports doug
ford is considering speeding up the plan
to ease public health restrictions eric
sorenson reports
ontario is bearing the brunt of
disruptions from ottawa to the border
crossings but one major political figure
has been out of sight premier ford
issued a statement that the ongoing
illegal occupation and blockade
happening in ontario must stop adding
that he's confident our police forces in
ontario the mounties and border services
will take the appropriate steps
ontario's liberal leader says ford must
do more than that doug ford's been in
hiding weak statements tweets that were
likely written by other people that's
not leadership in the midst of a crisis
now it's time to let the people in
ottawa get back to their lives that was
more than a week ago when ford last took
questions on camera about the protests
one reason for ford's low profile an
election just months away says this
analyst he doesn't want to
necessarily come out and embrace the the
various activities but at the same time
he doesn't want to polarize anybody
who's sympathetic to him ontario public
health plans to recommend lifting some
covid restrictions next week but not
because protesters are demanding it
without any external pressure because i
don't really watch the news too much
we are
absolutely committed
to removing public health measures in a
timely evidence-based science-driven
science driven manner across the country
governments are shifting ground on covet
restrictions it is time to remove these
restrictive and damaging health measures
alberta the first to drop vaccine
mandates others are resisting pressure
to do so too quickly one of the most
important things that we have now on our
side is that tool of protection through
vaccination we're still a lot out of
this one epidemiologist is worried that
amid the protests trust in science is
being politicized and as a result we
have
protesters
fringe thinking that seems to be
dictating some of this policy
and not surprisingly the policy is
falling along ideological lines for
governments and police there's
reluctance to be heavy-handed with
so-called freedom protests but with
supply chains being disrupted the
incentive to take action is growing that
could give politicians far more licensed
to get involved without being you know
seem to be cracking down on freedom but
instead being trying to defend the
economy back in ontario the attorney
general obtained a court order late
today to prohibit anyone from disposing
of or dealing with monetary donations
through the freedom convoy and adopt a
trucker campaign by way of the give send
go online fundraising platform
eric sorensen global news toronto
so where are canada's federal political
leaders on all this the prime minister
has implored the protesters to go home
the opposition conservatives have
supported the protesters and called on
justin trudeau to meet with them today
the new interim conservative leader
reversed course on part of that position
and called on the protesters to go home
does that signal newfound political
unity david aiken is with me from ottawa
david
well donna it was the threat to critical
infrastructure the real economic damage
that forced the conservatives to change
their minds on the blockades to all of
you who are taking part in the protests
i believe the time has come for you to
take down the barricades
stop the disruptive action and come
together
last week interim conservative leader
candice bergen had posed for pictures
with ottawa protesters and encouraged
them to stay but now in a speech in
parliament she pleaded with protesters
to leave the economy you want to see
reopen is hurting
farmers manufacturers
small businesses and families are
suffering
i believe this is not what you want to
do
same with kevin wah the conservative who
chairs his party's saskatchewan caucus
that caucus including former leader
andrew scheer also posed with truckers
last week and now wall wants them to go
the convoy's done one thing changed
minds in this country
it's time to move on the conservative
call to end the blockades came as they
pressed the trudeau government to come
up with a plan to end federal vaccine
mandates and to table that plan by the
end of the month not necessarily an end
to the mandates themselves just a road
map explaining to canadians how and when
they'll end two years into this pandemic
and given the current circumstances it's
not an unreasonable request mps will
vote on this idea later this week but it
sounds like the pm will vote against it
do you know what helps lift restrictions
you know what helps move beyond
lockdowns
vaccinations finally donna just as the
conservative position on the blockades
has now evolved the position of some
liberals on vaccine mandates also
continues to change a second quebec
liberal mp evrobiart has joined joel
lightbound in calling on their own
government to change their position on
vaccine mandates
all right david aiken in ottawa thank
you there is also a canada u.s border
crossing blocked in manitoba at emerson
protesters are using farm equipment and
semi-trucks there to block the emerson
pembina border crossing the rcmp says no
traffic is getting through in either
direction manitoba's justice minister
says it's time for the protest to end
it can't go on forever i think that a
point has been made i think that their
point has been heard
and
and i think that there's going to come a
time when
absolutely this we have to move on from
this
he's calling on the federal government
to do what it can to lower the
temperature with the protesters and in
alberta protesters are again blocking
traffic at the coots border crossing
that blockade resumed late tuesday
protesters say they will stay put even
though alberta's premier has ended the
proof of vaccination requirement there
heather urex west is near milk river
where an encampment of supporters is
growing heather how have the rcmp
stepped up enforcement
they have been issuing a soft touch
enforcement plan is what they call it
issuing tickets and asking protesters to
leave that has not been successful so
far the border remains blocked in this
encampment
has grown this afternoon is about a
kilometer worth of people and trucks
here camping in the ditch and on the
highway and protesters that we've spoken
with say that they are here for the long
haul even with our cmp issuing tickets
they say that until
vaccine mandates and covert restrictions
are lifted not only
in alberta but across the country
until those go away they say that they
will stay put
i just feel that we have to stand for
freedom i know that the more people that
we have standing for freedom
the stronger we all together a ticket to
me is a small price to pay at this point
standing your ground means standing your
ground holding your hold the line
that's that's very easy statement and so
you can read into that but
plain and simple it's people are not
going to back down
so they say they're not moving heather i
guess that means the rcmp have to do
something else what does it mean for the
border crossing itself
yeah it is completely blocked i can tell
you yesterday there were about 70 trucks
lined up here in milk river hoping to
get across the border that traffic has
since left either returning home or in
search of another route into the u.s now
the rcmp did tell us in an update
yesterday that protesters do need to go
and that their goal is to reopen traffic
uh flowing across the border we have
asked them today what they plan to do
next given that their soft touch
approach with ticketing does not seem to
be working we have not received an
answer so at this point it appears to be
an impasse here in southern alberta
donna
okay heather urix west near milk river
alberta tonight thanks
protests developing in europe coming up
what police in france are doing to stop
demonstrators from gathering in paris
[Music]
protests against public health
restrictions and vaccine mandates are
happening in other parts of the world
this is new zealand where police
arrested 122 people on the grounds of
parliament today the third day of
protests there and in europe a convoy is
making its way to paris for a
demonstration tomorrow french police say
they intend to stop protesters from
driving into the capitol warning
vehicles are banned from blocking roads
and drivers will face consequences
should they attempt to go ahead
crystal gomencing reports
honking horns a familiar sound to
canadians but this is france
trucks cars motorcycles and yes canadian
flags are out on the streets these
vehicles are a part of the european
freedom convoy apparently inspired by
actions first seen in ottawa
we saw the canadians and we said to
ourselves it's awesome what they are
doing and in eight days boom something
was triggered
it's unclear who started the european
convoy but it appears to have support
from france's yellowvest protesters in
2018 the group flooded the streets of
paris and at times clashed with police
escalations from demonstrations that
first started over rising fuel prices
i can't stand the pass anymore it's hell
says this man we must return to normal
ending all coped 19 restrictions seemed
to be one of the group's demands french
police are getting out ahead of the
convoy's arrival in paris friday
gatherings in the streets are now
prohibited between friday and monday and
citizens have been warned about
penalties for obstructing or interfering
with open roads up to two years in jail
and four thousand five hundred euros in
fines plus immobilization and
impoundment of vehicles excited
it's true that it's been said that they
cannot enter paris but i think that they
cannot block everyone from entering it's
impossible so i think they must force it
french authorities are on alert as are
officials in belgium after paris the
european freedom convoy is expected to
make its way to brussels
the headquarters of the european union
crystal commencing global news
london
flexing their firepower ahead russia
stages joint military drills with
belarus
prince charles has tested positive for
covet 19 for a second time the heir to
the british throne has canceled all his
upcoming engagements and is
self-isolating he is triple vaccinated
on wednesday prince charles and his wife
camilla mingled with dozens of people at
a reception there are reports he also
met the queen two days ago at windsor
she's being closely monitored prince
charles had coveted in march of 2020
with only mild symptoms
russia has begun joint military drills
with belarus a close ally of russia
about 30 000 russian troops are believed
to be taking part in the exercises nato
says it is moscow's biggest deployment
to belarus since the cold war belarus
shares a long border with ukraine russia
has amassed more than 100 000 troops
along its own border with ukraine
surrounding it on three sides
nato has stepped up military deployments
too to bolster its eastern flank in
poland and romania
this is probably the most dangerous
moment
i would say in the course of the next
few days in what is the uh biggest
security crisis that europe has faced
for decades and
we've got to get it right
russia continues to say it has no plans
to invade ukraine and demands the west
keep ukraine and other former soviet
republics out of nato
next from skates to skis team canada
shines brighter with a cluster of new
metals
canada's isabelle weidemann skated her
way to even more olympic success weidman
won the silver medal in the women's
speed skating 5000 meters it is the 26
year old's second medal in beijing she
won bronze in the 3 000 meter race
quebec's elliott grondon came within a
hair of olympic gold in snowboard cross
he lost by just two one hundredths of a
second really a photo finish granda is
only 20 years old and is now the
youngest ever snowboard cross olympic
medalist and team canada is jumping into
the history books freestyle skiers
marion tenno niha fontaine and louis
irving won bronze in the first ever
olympic mixed team aerials event which
made its debut in beijing
and toronto's jack crawford clinched
canada's first ever bronze medal in
combined alpine skiing crawford
absolutely crushed his downhill section
putting down the second fastest time and
capped it off with a strong performance
in slalom to stay in metal contention
and with all that canada is now ranked
third winning one gold medal four silver
and seven bronze
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
here canada is winnipeg manitoba ah look
at that thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you